hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're gonna talk about how to get rid of
puffy eyes and those bags and underneath the
eyes okay now I'm just gonna let you
know the cucumber slices don't really
work long-term or creams and everything
this is all an internal problem it's
mainly a kidney problem now I can see
people across the street and look at
their eyes and they're all puffy and I'm
like oh that's a kidney issue now
anytime you have a kidney issue you're
gonna have a liver issue so they're
almost similar in problems you can't
have a really sick kidney and a healthy
liver okay because they both work
together but the kidney is a detoxifier
it basically takes all your blood it's a
filter it's like an oil filter and it
filters the blood so here's what happens
with a kidney
number one you can be consuming
excess cooked protein too much protein
so let's say you're sitting down for
dinner and you're just loading up this
huge huge plate of chicken wings or
chicken fingers and you have absolutely
no vegetables nothing to counter that
you're getting a lot of protein that's
going to eventually turn into uric acid
crystals and a lot of excessive waste
because your body can't process more
than a certain amount of protein so
anything extra your it strains the
kidneys and the liver okay so a protein
can mess it up in large amounts how much
protein do you need three to six ounces
that's just a little bit
you don't need tremendous amounts so
excessive protein and too little
vegetable people that have the bags have
the kidney problems usually don't ever
eat vegetables okay they don't you need
to start doing that if you have this
problem because this also relates to the
potassium levels in the body you have so
much potassium and so much sodium they
work together and fluid retention
usually as a sodium excess well if you
just have your normal potassium amounts
that alone will flush out the sodium and
get rid of the fluid so we need four
times as much potassium to sodium so a
lot of people have it reversed they're
doing
four times as much sodium to potassium
and they're just like fluid water lock
and you can see it in the ankles there's
pitting edema
but this situation it's really the
vegetable has the most of the potassium
and then you're not going to get a lot
of potassium from proteins so then we
have alcohol right so alcohol messes
with your kidney
it messes with your liver it crates the
bags a lot of people think that's normal
to drink alcohol on a regular basis they
drink a bottle of wine two bottles of
wine and you think well that's fine well
here's the question can you give it up
if you can't give it up then you're
probably addicted okay so then we have
the MSG monosodium glutamate
monosodium glutamate is a flavor enhancer
it's in all the Chinese restaurants and
they hide it not as much monosodium
glutamate they hide it as modified food
starch and what it's a lot of sodium
that's not salty so you're gonna walk
away and just drink fluid and you're
just like gonna fill up with fluid
really fast so it's a water retainer and
it's a flavor enhancer it also spikes
insulin too and then we have just
straight sugar and junk food that's
going to mess with your kidneys so we
need 4700 milligrams of potassium that
would be seven to ten cups of vegetables
a lot of times people say well I don't
want to have much potassium because I
heard that it might damage the kidneys
let me let me just give you the truth in
the kidney unless you're on kidney
dialysis unless you're stage like a real
bad kidney where you're like end-stage
kidney failure everything else you can
do potassium the fact it's shown that
potassium protects the kidney it doesn't
worsen the kidney you need potassium to
protect the kidney it's just that when
the kidney is so damaged
you can't process potassium and it
starts to increase because you're not
getting rid of it so you need so much
potassium but your body gets rid of that
much potassium every day - so if the
kidneys can't do that you could end up
with a lot of potassium which is
dangerous to the heart but again for
those of you there aren't good analysis
okay you can't
the potassium but the cool thing is
we're not even talking about taking in
the supplement we're just taking getting
it from vegetables so you're gonna be
more safe with that then you have
another cause of kidney problems which
would be the prostate enlargement what
happened is the prostate when it
enlarges it actually pushes up into the
bladder okay it pushed up in the bladder
and it restricts the amount of urine the
bladder can hold and then the urine
backs up through these two little pipes
are called
the ureter s'okay and they go right to
the kidney and then what happens the
kidneys can't filter the urine so it
backs up and the kidneys start getting
larger and larger
so that's really what would mess up the
kidney - is having a prostate
enlargement I had one guy and all we did
is some simple acupressure you can
actually work on these points with a
massage tool you can work on them and
it's interesting what will happen you'll
have it probably really tight and
painful and congested you do it lightly
and you keep working it out I've had so
many people do that and all of a sudden
just dump all this excess fluids from
their bodies it's quite dramatic so
that's just a side point so we got the
kidney and then number two we have blood
sugars so usually when someone's
hypoglycemic insulin resistance or a
diabetic they usually a puffiness
underneath the eyes just because
wherever the sugar goes that the water
goes so they have a lot of water
retention in pockets and the ankles and
the hands in the eyes I mean underneath
the eyes so what you want to do with if
you have blood sugar issues you want to
do 3 to 6 ounces of protein with each
meal don't don't do a lot but don't cut
it out completely because you need some
7 cups of vegetables that's not hard to
do right you probably need more but
that's a good start that will increase
and help the blood sugars and help
insulin regulate itself and then we need
a little healthy fat to allow you to go
from one meal to the next so we're not
snacking so that's just I'll put some
links down below if this is your first
video and you've never seen the data on
how to and correct blood Sugar's but
that would be one cause this
far as the kidneys the kidneys do well
on a lot of vegetables a little bit of
protein and just so happens one of the
things that are good for the kidney is
the kidney bean what a coincidence it's
shaped like a kidney all right so apply
this information all right guys so thank
you so much for watching I'll see you in the
next video